- [Interviewer] So you started with
- Acid. I smoked weed for a little bit.
I didn't really like it.
So then I went to cocaine
and then graduated to heroin.
- [Interviewer] This is all like,
when you were in high school?
- Yeah.
I have a very curious mind
so I wanted to know
what it was really like.
I found out. (laughs)
- [Interviewer] How old are you now?
- 47.
- [Interviewer] 47.
So you've been doing
drugs since you were 14.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And I
mean, when you were 14, 13,
when you were a young girl,
what did you envision for your life?
What did you dream?
- What did I dream? I
thought I was going to be
at least a nurse or
something like my mother.
And it just didn't turn out that way.
You know, there was a lot of molestation,
dysfunctional stuff at home.
I'm not going to get into that,
but just, I had this very fucked up life.
- [Interviewer] Very unsettled childhood.
- So I ran away from home
and I was like, fuck that.
You know what I mean?
I don't need you guys.
- [Interviewer] And drugs were as escape.
- You know?
And one thing I always,
I read it in the Bible when I was young,
but I never really took
it into to my heart
that your family will be the
first ones to fuck you over.
And it's true. Yeah. It's very true.
You know, your family,
it fucked me over when I was a young age,
sexually molested me as my mother watched.
So I was very, very angry
and I felt like I wanted
to do something to them.
So I said it was best for me to go on.
- [Interviewer] Was this your dad?
- [Jennifer] Yeah. Yeah.
That's all I'm going to
say on that matter, though.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I'm
sorry. I don't mean to pry.
So that kind of derails
your plans for life.
- [Jennifer] Yeah. Yeah.
But it's never too late to start over.
You know what I mean?
You know, and I still got
a whole life ahead of me.
- [Interviewer] No, and you're
- [Jennifer] I got a good head.
I got a very good head on my shoulders.
I'm not crazy.
And I'm not high right now.
So you know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- [Jennifer] You know,
I could turn it around.
- [Interviewer] No, you're
not too old to do that.
Yeah, you can do amazing things still.
But the key is to get off this.
- [Jennifer] I would like to thank you
for letting me share a little
bit of my world with you.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. So, I mean,
when you're down here on
the street, you sleep where?
- [Jennifer] Here and there.
- [Interviewer] Just wherever?
- [Jennifer] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And typically
you generate money by?
- [Jennifer] Prostituting or
doing whatever I have to do.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Do whatever you can wherever you can.
You're surviving.
- [Jennifer] I've got to get
going though, babe. (laughs)
- [Interviewer] Okay, I'm sorry.
Thank you for talking to me though.
- [Jennifer] Yeah. Money, money.
- [Interviewer] How have you made money
in the last 24 hours?
- Prostitution.
- [Interviewer] And how
safe do you feel doing that?
- I don't really feel safe,
but it is what it is, you know?
I haven't been extremely hurt, ever hurt.
I've been beat up a little bit.
I've been raped a few times,
but in the 33 years that
I've been on the street,
I haven't really been hurt, you know?
I've been in a couple of close calls.
I remember I got picked up by this guy
who I thought was a security guard.
He had at security jacket,
so that threw me off.
He turned out to be a serial killer.
And I was his next intended victim.
But God was with me.
- [Interviewer] How do you
know he was a serial killer?
- Because, we were,
the police followed us.
- [Interviewer] Oh, really?
- He kidnapped me and took
me to two counties away.
- [Interviewer] Oh, you're kidding.
- Yeah.
And if it wouldn't have
been for the police
putting him under surveillance,
I'd be dead right now.
- [Interviewer] So the
police followed you home
two counties away?
- We were at a Dolly Madison parking lot.
You know Dolly Madison, right?
- [Interviewer] I don't.
- It's like, they're like Hostess.
- [Interviewer] Oh,
it's like a snack food.
- Yeah.
It was kind of scary, you know?
He choked me.
He choked me, I couldn't
talk for two weeks after it.
He had me chained down with
a big chain in the front seat
butt naked, butt ass
naked, as he's choking me.
- [Interviewer] He had you chained?
- Yes. Yes.
- [Interviewer] And he was choking you.
- Yeah.
The police had been looking
for him for 10 years.
- [Interviewer] And the
cops broke in and entered.
- Yep.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- Helicopters, I heard helicopters.
At the last minute, I heard helicopters.
Loud, you know?
I looked up,
it was like my savior,
you know what I'm saying?
I've never been so happy to
see the police in my life.
That's a true story.
He got 99 and a half years in prison.
He ain't never going out.
- [Interviewer] That's
an incredible story.
He was white, black, Hispanic?
- He was Jamaican. Yeah.
I remember his car, he had a black Sentra.
- [Interviewer] And he
had murdered other women?
- Yeah.
He had murdered four
prostitutes, South central.
- [Interviewer] And here
you are still doing it.
- Yeah.
Sometimes you don't
suffer enough, you know?
Sometimes I think that I
don't deserve to be alive.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't deserve to be happy, you know?
Because all it seems my life consists of,
bad relationships, drugs
and selling my body.
There's no love in my life, you know?
I can't really say that I've ever
been in love because I've
never given it a chance.
You know what I'm saying?
So I always question
people's motives, you know?
- [Interviewer] It's amazing
how life can get derailed.
- Yeah, it is, and in a heartbeat.
It can happen so fast.
And what started it was when
my mom and dad got divorced.
That's what started everything downhill.
- [Interviewer] Your parents' divorce?
- Yeah. When I was 13.
I was like, oh, I don't care,
if they're not happy, they
don't need to be together.
But I didn't know that it
was gonna affect me so bad.
You know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] It weakened you.
- Yeah. It did. It did.
So then I was like, okay,
so now my mom and dad
don't love you no more.
That's what I believe.
- [Interviewer] Were your
parents still in your life?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I lived with my dad.
And during that period,
I was also being sexually
molested by my dad, you know?
So here we go again, I'm
learning sex, sex, sex.
That's all I know
You know, so it became
a way of life, you know?
So when I got turned out as a prostitute
it wasn't a surprise to me.
And that I was also very good at it
because, well of course,
all my life I'd be doing it.
- [Interviewer] You had practice.
- Yeah.
Today's not really a good day
because I woke up with
diarrhea, throwing up, you know,
I need to go and get me some
dope, you know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] Sorry?
- I need to go and get some (taps arm)